lost in the chaos yesterday was the fact
that democrats are now set to take
control of the u.s
senate after winning both senate runoff
elections
in georgia senior national correspondent
mark strassman
has more from atlanta
a noisy victory lap for georgia
democrats tuesday
after handing republicans a double
defeat it's about time we had someone in
washington who's thinking about
ordinary people and so i can't wait to
get to work for them
whether you were for me or against me
i'll be for you
in the u.s senate warnock will be
georgia's first black senator
ossoff will be the state's first jewish
senator at 33
he's the youngest elected u.s senator
since joe biden
both republican candidates led at 11 p.m
on election night
but metro atlanta increasingly
progressive was the game changer
at 11 18 p.m dekalb county reported
nearly 166 thousand votes
catapulting warnock into the lead and a
few hours later
ossoff joined him neither democrat
trailed again
while neither republican candidate has
conceded their race
one of georgia's top republican election
officials said
both democrats appear to have enough
votes to avoid a recount
while republicans were busy attacking
the governor and my boss
the democrats were out there knocking on
doors and getting people to turn out to
vote
gabriel sterling is the chief operating
officer in the secretary of state's
office
he blames president trump for the gop's
loss
after the president spent weeks
spreading baseless claims
of election fraud there's no way we lost
georgia there's no way
when you say your vote doesn't count
then you have people who are
you've laid your hands on said these are
my people who say don't come and vote
then you spark a civil war within a gop
that needed to be united to get through
a tough fight like this
neither of these democrats has ever held
public officers before
neither of the republicans they beat has
conceded
gail mark thank you very much